on talk of this afternoon
given by lee young
it's
wonk sorry
and and it's about the haitian informed
mirror descent with applications in
gradient flow thank you
thanks for the introduction so first i
would like to thank katie and simon for
the nice invitation
so this is my first time travel after
pandemic so it's great to be here i'm
keeping my finger crossed not to catch
the virus though
um so today i'm going to talk about this
hessian informed mirror descent with
applications in gradient flow so this is
a joint work with me yen from michigan
state university
here is the outline so first i will give
an introduction to the algorithm which
is a special type of mirror descent and
then i'll present you with some
convergence analysis result
and then apply this method to compute
the gradient flow
so this is the problem we are
considering it is a linear constraint
optimization so f is a convex
differentiable function
from omega to r so omega is a subset of
rn so that means this u is a vector of
size n
and for instance f can take this form
and i guess is for me looks familiar to
most of you um
so this kind of energy potential appears
in many places such as aggregation
dynamics or kinetic description of
granular gas or mean field limit of
neural networks
this a is a matrix of size m by n and
here we are assuming that this m is much
smaller than n so that means we only
have a very limited amount of
constraints
for instance if we consider this a to be
an all one row vector
and this omega will require all the
components of u to be non-negative then
we have this simplex constraint
i guess there's no need for me to say
how important these questions is because
actually in many applications in the end
of the day it just reduces to this
linearly constrained optimization
because of this there are many methods
to solve this problem so here i'm
omitting all the literature and just
focus on the mirror descent and in fact
there are different ways to understand
uh mirror descent and here i'm just
going to explain our own viewpoint
which as you will see can be easily
extend to
the general variable metric method
and i need to say that our viewpoint is
highly inspired by the paper of lashing
in
in 2020 and i see that le shin is giving
a talk on friday about this so i believe
he will give you more perspectives
so here the starting point of the mirror
descent is to uh first to find this
convex function phi of u or sometimes
you called mirror map
and then we can view this mirror descent
through this following update formula
so gratify evaluated at uk plus one that
that's the iteration at the k plus one
step
is related to the iteration at the k
step um in the following way so this eta
m that's the iteration uh step
and this blue part that comes from the
constraint so this c of u actually is uh
to be determined vector so just see i
just view this c of u as the lagrange
multiplier
so in particular if you choose this phi
of u to be u square over 2 then this
mirror descent just simply reduces to
this gradient descent and actually more
precisely is the projected gradient
descent
so at every iteration you just run the
gradient descent and then you project it
into onto your constraint set
um and i need to emphasize that um so
since we assume that uh this m is much
smaller than n and this c is the place
the row of lagrange multiplier so this c
actually is of size m
and since m is very small so in practice
it should be easy to
obtain this c so either through newton
iteration or bisection method
for example if we consider this simplex
uh constraint
where here you can see that we only have
one constraint so it's just a summation
of u equals one and that means we just
need to find the scalar constant c so in
this case um
the appropriate choice of phi is this
entropy functional and if if you plug in
this one to the mirror descent and this
is the update formula you're going to
get
and to obtain this c is encoded in this
normalizing constant so in this case
it's very easy to obtain c you just
normalize it by this constant z
okay now we want to put this mirror
descent into the into a more general
framework of variable metric method
and for that we
define this phi star which is the convex
conjugate of phi
then it is straightforward to check this
identity
and then if you start from this identity
you will see that this uk plus one
equals this grad phi star of graph phi
at uk
plus one and then we plug in this mirror
descent update here
and this is what get and then we conduct
the taylor expansion keep only the
leading two terms so the first term
reduces to uk again through this
identity and for the second term um so
we use this relation which i mark
a marked in purple here
which is obtained by taking the gradient
in u
of this identity
so in the end this thing just reduces to
the inverse of the hessian so multiplied
by the gradient
so you can see that in the end we can
say we can see we can obtain this
approximated formula of the mirror
descent which is nothing but the
variable metric method where the metric
is induced by the hessian of phi
in other words you can you can
understand this way by um originally you
want to minimize over f and in practice
you just find an approximation of f so
it's a quadratic approximation
and if you choose phi to be uh u squared
over 2 then this just reduces to to the
gradient descent and if you choose 5 to
be f then this is just the newton's
method
so in other words you can just say that
this variable metric method and mirror
descent are just a first order
approximation of each other
and what's more interesting is that if
we send eta which is the iteration step
to zero
then they arrive at the same continuous
flow
so
in summary we can always say we start
from the continuous flow
and the view the mirror descent and the
variable metric methods as the first
order discretization of this continuous
flow
and we know that
one of the most popular
variable metric methods is the newton's
method because of its fast convergence
so it's natural to think that if this
file can include some information of f
then we can get
faster convergence
so that's what i'm going to show next so
basically with this special choice of f
i'll show that both the global and local
convergence of the
mirror descent
and the point i want to make here is
that actually we can use the
framework to show the global convergence
of the mirror descent to prove the
global convergence for the general
variable metric method
and in return we can use the framework
to show
the framework that's showing the super
linear local convergence for the newton
type method
to show the super linear local
convergence for the mirror descent
okay so let's look at the uh
global sublinear convergence first
um by examining this continuum flow
so this is the
this is the result so basically it says
if you evaluate f at this time average
solution it will converge to the minimum
at the rate of 1 over t multiplied by
this fragment divergence
so this is how the bragging divergence
is defined so it's just a local
quadratic
measure
so here i'm presenting you the result of
the continuum flow because it's much
much more neat and actually the proof is
is inspired from uh just a classical
proof for the convergence of mirror
descent
and
and it's based on checking this time
derivative of the bragman divergence so
using the convexity of f we can show
that this time
time derivative of this fragment
divergence
is less than or equal to this difference
and then we can integrate this equal
inequality from zero to capital t
and divided by t
and then again using the convexity of f
and also the non-negativity of the
bragging divergence then we can arrive
at this inequality
so similar results can be uh obtained at
the discrete level of course for mirror
descent that's how we that's actually
how we obtain the continuum result but
what's more interesting is that we can
obtain similar results for the general
variable metric method
so
in fact in
instead of just analyzing the time
derivative of this fragment divergence
we can just analyze the the difference
of the fragment diverges
and also uh the convergence result is
that if you evaluate f at this agardic
sum and it's going to converge the
minimum at the rate of one over uh
square root of k
okay
uh
it's come back this is it's just
contacts yes okay no strong no yes the
strong convex is what i'm going to show
next okay yeah so actually you can
improve the
sublinear convergence to linear
convergence if you assume f is strong
convex
so um so in particular if you um if we
can define these two fragment divergence
one is with respect to
phi and the other is with respect to f
and
so if we assume that the ratio of this
df
over d phi is bounded below by mu
then we can show that um the the bragman
divergence actually has this exponential
decay
where obviously this mu controls this
linear convergence rate
and if we choose this phi to be again u
square over 2 then this condition just
says we require f to be mu strongly
convex and we know that in practice
this mu can be very close to zero so
that leads to a very
slow convergence
convergence rate
but uh um here because we have the
freedom to choose phi
so we can actually bump up this mu to be
some other one constant and that leads
to a much
faster convergence
okay so
and then we can move on to show the uh
the local convergence
so for the local convergence the goal is
to show that as long as this phi
contains enough information of f then we
can get super linear convergence
and the proof follows the two stage
proof for the newton-type method
so the first stage is
summarized in the in the following
proposition
so it says if this phi if we assume phi
is one strongly convex with respect to
the usual uh standard norm and this grad
f is ellipsis and if the iteration step
is properly chosen so basically it's
smaller
than the minimum of the two
then we have the objective function
decreases sufficiently so this alpha is
between
zero and a half
so this is also called the
sufficiently decreased
condition
and then um we can
so after we we run the first stage for
so after we run the iteration for long
enough then we enter into the second
stage
um so
basically it tells you how does this f
should close should be close to uh sorry
five should be close to f so first we
look at the following lemma so this g so
g defined in the uh following way
so if g is close to f in the following
sense which which is what called
dennis moore condition
so if you look at uh this g which
relates to the hessian of phi so
basically tells you that the hessian of
phi should be close enough to the
hessian of f which is not surprising
so if this one converges to zero as k
goes to infinity
then we can choose eta equals one
such that the the scheme still satisfies
the sufficient descent condition for a
large enough case so that means we have
to run the first stage
large enough
and then once we can choose this eta to
be one
then we enter the second stage of the
algorithm and we get the super linear
convergence which is uh stated in the
following theorem so if this g satisfies
this then is more condition and
f is beta strongly convex
then the mirror descent converges super
linearly in the following sense so
basically is this uh uk plus one
converges to u uh much faster or is a
little o of uh uk minus u star
okay so now we want to apply uh this
method to uh the
uh to the gradient flow so the first
example is the uh wasserstein gradient
flow so i think i do not need to say uh
too much about this equation so it's
very familiar to the audience
um so rho is the probability then
density so the time derivative of rho
follows this
steepest descent of the
energy with respect to the western style
in two metric
and uh uh this energy takes this for a
general uh form so this u is the
potential energy uh this v of x is the
um
is the potential and this uh w is the
interaction kernel
um
and again there are actually there is a
huge literature on computing this was a
sign gradient flow and i'm again
omitting those literature and just
explain our approach which is a
variational approach or
what we call the jko scheme
so um again i guess you are familiar
with the jko scheme so basically if you
get if you know the density at time tn
then you can
obtain the density and next time step by
uh
by solving this minimization problem
so the objective function consists of
two terms one is the uh waterslide two
distance to the previous uh density
weighted by this one over two tau and
the second is the energy term
so in this case actually we are not
going to solve this wassasan 2
distance exactly instead we are going to
approximate it by this weighted
h minus 1 norm
so
so actually the ratio now is that we
know that this was this jko scheme is
just a first order approximation to the
original what's the style gradient flow
so actually we can have a little bit of
approximation
for this what's the sign to distance
okay so we are using this h minus one uh
norm to approximate the watson sign two
uh uh distance and this is how we define
this weighted h minus one norm so um so
this uh uh la pla so this laplacian row
n that's the weighted laplacian
okay so now the question boils down to
how to solve this minimization um
problem and of course we are going to
use the
mirror descent and we know that the
whole point of this mirror descend is to
choose this uh
potential function phi
and uh this is what we are going to
choose so first we pick part of the
objective function
and the reason is that if you look at
the objective function um because this
tau so this tile is not the iteration
step it's actually the time step we did
we used to discretize the flow
and again because this is the first
order approximation we cannot we cannot
uh use too big of a tau because that
will introduce too much of numerical
error so this tau is small so that to
say this term is more pronounced
compared to the uh to the second term
and another reason is that this is a
quadratic term so if you take the
gradient then you all have a linear
function on a row and this one is a it
can be a very wild so it's a nonlinear
function on row so that's another reason
and the second term so this epsilon
actually we can tune it so it's a it's a
free parameter
so the second term is an entropy on row
and the reason to put it there is to
impose this uh non-negativity of rho so
because we know that the solution to
this watson gradient flow has to be
non-negative
okay so um once we once we determine
this potential function phi then we just
plug it into
this mirror descent algorithm
and here i need to emphasize that
originally so we still have the
constraint so it's the mass constraint
so that means the integral of rho
should be a constant
and here i didn't put a constraint there
as what i did before and the reason is
um so if after a little bit of change so
here um if i apply this weighted
laplacian on both sides
so this is what i'm going to get from
this equation
and because we only have this mass
constraint so that means we i only have
a constant there
and if i apply this uh weighty laplacian
to that constant vector
then i'm going to get zero as long as i
discretize this weighted laplacian in a
conservative way
so that to say so that's a good news so
we don't even need to do any kind of
normalization it's already embedded in
the algorithm
so that to say
here we can automatically get this
positivity because we have uh
this entropy term in the in the in the
potential function and the mass
conservation is guaranteed by the
conservative discretization of this uh
weighted laplacian
and there is another one last thing we
need to be careful is that if you look
at this update it's still so we need to
obtain this row k plus 1. so on the left
hand side is still a nonlinear equation
on row k so we need to apply some kind
of newton iteration
and actually the solution to the
gradient flow
the the magnitude of rho
can vary largely and especially it have
some support that row is very very close
to zero so in that case on the system we
are going to solve is very ill
conditioned
so what we can do is that we just build
a very simple effective preconditioner
and use this preconditioner that we can
solve this nonlinear system um very
easily
and this is uh two examples so the first
one is the
first medium equation so what i'm
showing on the left that's the evolution
of the
baron light
profile
so overlay so the dash curve that's the
analytical solution
so what's in the middle is the number of
iterations needed at each time step so
you can see that we just need a quite
limited number of iterations for the
skin to converge so around 50 50 to 60.
so this is a huge reduction
compared to the primal dual method we
used before
and um and here um so so the the the
third picture is the it's just one
typical um uh error versus the number of
iteration and you can see that the error
decay decays very fast so after 50
iterations it already decays to 10 to
minus 8.
and the second example is the
aggregation equation so with this
special
choice of the interaction kernel uh we
know that um the steady state will
satisfy the semi circle law
so here um so again this is the
evolution and this is the number of
iteration at each time step so you can
see that overall we need a small number
of iterations but occasionally
we have some we have a few picks so that
actually uh corresponding to the sharp
change of solutions because here the
solution is very very close to zero so
once you have this sharp um so once you
have the
this propagation of the sharp front
then
occasionally you will need a larger
number of iterations and again this is
one of the worst case so actually this
corresponding to uh this time step
so you you need a little bit more
iteration to converge to ten to minus
eight but not but yeah but not not a
huge number it's just around 200.
next we uh extend uh the results to um
the
can heliod equation with nonlinear uh
mobility so you can see that you can
view this one as a generalization to the
wasserstein gradient flow
so we know that the can helium equation
is a typical model in
material science to model the
interfacial dynamics of this binary
alloy so this u is just a
concentration difference between two
components of the alloy
and here i'm i'm using this m of u which
is y minus u squared so if uh in the
classical case that's just a one so
that's a constant and for the what's the
sign gradient flow this m of u is just u
but here we are considering this uh
nonlinear function on u and actually the
degenerate uh is a degenerate mobility
so the solution okay so energy takes
this form so it has two components so
the first one is panelized uh on
the edge and the second one is sometimes
we take it as the ginsberg landau
energy functional but here we are using
this one half of one minus u squared so
basically um the solution to uh to this
equation stays
bounded above by one and uh below by
minus one
and uh again so we are using the similar
framework as we uh compute the was
assigned gradient flow so we are using
this variational uh framework
so the only difference is that um here
we are we have a more complicated uh
weighted h minus one one but uh it's
just we replace this m of u equals u to
this nonlinear uh mobility
and again if we were to apply this
mirror descent then we need to choose
the uh
the potential function phi and this is
what we get
um so
so similar as before we are we are
choosing this part of the objective
function to uh to this potential phi
but we are adding two additional terms
so originally the solution is uh
non-negative so we add the entropy term
but here we want to impose the
boundedness of the solution so the
solution is bounded by
negative one to one so that's why i'm
adding this lower bound and upper bound
so
again so once we choose this potential
function that i just plugged into the
mirror descent update and then i got to
solve the nonlinear equation and we use
similar pre-conditioner
and
this is the result we get so this one is
actually harder to compute but
so on the left hand side still we uh
we converge to the equilibrium which is
marked in this dashed curve
and on the right i'm showing you the um
the number of iterations so here you can
see that on it is harder to converge um
than the previous case which which is
not surprising because of the because
this um yeah degeneracy on in the
mobility so with that i'm going to end
my talk and see if you have questions
thank you very much for the very nice
talk
so is there any question comment
hi uh thank you so just a very very
naive question so when you are doing the
uh doing the
trying to compute the washer strand
gradient flow you're actually modifying
the problems so by computing uh changing
the washer shine to some
other
yeah
h minus one thing so
so this is very silly but why do you
get the same continuity equation
that's a good question actually so we
didn't prove we didn't prove the we
didn't prove the convergence of uh
yeah so
i wouldn't say that this is it's obvious
that this one so this form will converge
to the same
um
[Music]
same gradient flow but the idea is that
because this one yeah this one is a it's
the first order approximation to the
wasn't signed to distance and
jko scheme is the first order
approximation to the uh
to the what's inside gradient flow
so so in that sense we are not too off
but you have a finalization over
you mean here
no so already so here okay so this one
is proofed already so this one is right
yes but this one oh you are saying that
you um you have this one over uh
two two tau in front of it
well i have to say that this this is not
an easy problem to prove that the uh
yeah this the solution to this one
converges to that so i don't yeah i
don't think it's a it's a it's an easy
question yeah but uh
but i think numerically it's not a crazy
idea to approximate that
thank you professor for a nice talk uh i
want to know could you comment like to
compare
this message with your prime to message
to compute the versus gradient flow
what's the advantage and what's the
disadvantage yeah so um the advantage is
that the convergence is much faster so
as as you can see from here actually if
you if yeah i didn't i didn't put the
comparison here but if we can if you
check the number of iterations needed to
converge then this is much smaller than
that but i have to say that here um
um
yeah so
i'm thinking of applying this method to
a more general uh class but the problem
is that i need this w to be
differentiable
so in
yeah so in general this w doesn't have
to be differentiable but in this
framework i need it to be differentiable
so yes i'm thinking that whether i could
generalize this framework to
non-differentiable uh
energy potential yeah and then that w
actually yeah not w but actually the
general e generally
so
um
yeah and i think another advantage of
the primo 2 is that theoretically it's
more it's more settled like what uh
lehigh just asked so that one you can
prove that it's convergent so here we
don't have any uh we cannot prove that
the solution here converges to the
continuum grading flow
[Music]
can you talk a little bit about how you
enforce the positivity constraints or if
there are any other choices you
considered perhaps by modifying your
constraint set or anything oh actually
uh yeah so here so for the positivity
that here this one is already guaranteed
so this is
if you use so if you choose non-non-zero
epsilon no matter how actually epsilon
doesn't have to be small because this
this this um
yeah this phi doesn't have to be that
close to f so if it is close enough we
have super linear convergence but
actually in practice you you just get a
faster linear convergence that's good
enough so actually this this epsilon
doesn't have to be small so as long as
you have a non-zero epsilon then
positivity is guaranteed from here
so
so that's why in the next example that
if i want to impose the bound then i can
just uh build it in into my file so
that's a that's a good thing about this
mirror descent so you have you have the
freedom to choose this potential fight
to impose this bound
so probably is the perfect time to
continue the discussion during the break
so let's think they speak again
you